we are learning new details about the
death of a prominent Hollywood therapist
and former fiance of comedian drew Carey
38 year old Amy Harwick was killed
Saturday at her Hollywood Hills home the
case raises questions about domestic
violence and stalking her former
boyfriend Gareth purse house has been
charged with her murder
Cary who hosts the prices right of
course says he's overcome with grief
Erin Moriarity talked with people close
to Harwick about her final moments for
this week's 48 hours safety is important
so feelings of personal safety emotional
safety if amy Harvick's best friend
robert kosslyn was texting with her just
before she died one week ago I sent her
my last text at probably 11 o'clock at
night she responded to me at like 101
a.m. minutes later police found Amy near
death under a balcony at her home she
had injuries consistent with a fall and
the coroner says there was evidence of
strangulation
Amy's ex-boyfriend Gareth pers house was
arrested and charged with her murder she
was like if I ever disappear or if
anything ever happens to me it's him Amy
had ended her relationship with purse
house years ago but just last month at a
professional event she had a chance
encounter with him that's purse house
there he came like over to her all like
yelling at her he was yelling in her
face saying you ruined my life you know
created a giant scene sobbing wailing
their past relationship had been rough
Amy had filed for restraining orders
against him twice
detailing physical abuse the last one
expired in 2015 she was afraid because
he had acted so crazy so she had always
been afraid that he might do something
violent Amy's friend and fellow
therapist Hernando Chavez was there when
she ran into purse house he looked upset
in duress she was trying to soothe and
calm and he was agitated was she scared
after that confrontation even though she
was calming him down was she scared she
was
scared of what scared of the what-ifs
Amy Hardwick was devoted to helping
people all these things can be focused
on his ways to care about yourself to
build on yourself but her friend Ashley
Willis says there was another side of
her she was very creative and artsy she
was a dancer a photographer even at one
time a fire eater and now a terrible
loss her friends wonder what more could
have been done to protect her what will
you miss about her the most is it one
thing that you just think her just her
you know hear her voice in my head and
Erin Moriarty joins us now from Los
Angeles where she's still working on
this story Erin good morning good
morning this is such a sad story Anthony
it really is the more I get to know Amy
Hardwick the more I wish I had known her
yeah she's an impressive young woman
Erin do we know why after that recent
encounter with with pers house or her
ex-boyfriend which was which was so
confrontational do we know why she
didn't go to police again to get yet
another restraining order well she
talked about it with friends but she's a
therapist she deals with victims and she
knows how the system works and it's not
always easy to get an order of
protection you have to show that there
is a pattern you have to show that your
stalker really poses a threat and we
know that there was just one encounter
and she told her friends that he didn't
actually threaten her she calmed him
down so I think she decided and she did
she added cameras she had a roommate I
think she decided to focus on the
security in her home and it just didn't
work Erin
drew Carey her former fiance has said
he's overcome with grief and in a
statement to CBS said that they had a
love that people are lucky to have once
in a lifetime do we know what he's doing
now to honor her legacy well Toni mostly
he is putting his support behind these
petitions that will be sent to the
governor the petitions are asking for
tighter sits stalking laws and at this
moment I was told that they have 50,000
signatures but they're hoping for a
million
all right Aaron thank you very much you
can see Aaron's full report the life and
death of Amy Harwick tomorrow night at
10:00 9:00 central right here on CBS